welcome to angular firebase today I'm
going to show you how to create separate
back-end environments for development
and production with angular for
maintaining separate environments allows
you to build and test new features
without screwing up data from your live
production app step one create two fire
based projects before jumping into the
code you'll need two separate projects
on fire firebase one for development and
one for production step 2 create the
environment files in this case I have
cloned the fire starter app from github
and the first step is to create the
environment file files manually if you
create a new app with the angular CLI
then these files are going to be here by
default and then also make sure to add
these files to your git ignore because
they hold sensitive credentials and you
don't want that ending up in a public
repo step 3
paste in the firebase configuration into
each of the environment files step 4
bootstrap the environment in the app
module now we can import the environment
variables anywhere in our app in this
case we want to bootstrap the firebase
configuration directly in the app module
the code you're looking at right now is
what is specifically needed to wire up
angular firebase with these separate
environments in your app module
step 5 serve or compile the app with
that done it's possible to serve the app
locally using either environment all we
have to do is add the prod to ng serve
and that'll serve the app in production
thanks for watching I'll see you on the
other side
[Music]
you